I tell you the Zebras story hmm you any
of you know that story okay I'll tell
you this zebras story tell it stop me if
I told it to you before this tells you
everything you need to know about human
beings so it's worth it's worth it's
worth knowing
okay so zebras have stripes and people
say well that's for camouflage and then
you think about that for two seconds and
you think that's a really stupid theory
because lions are camouflaged and
they're like golden like the grass and
zebras are black and white so you can
see a zebra five miles away it's like
there's a zebra it's black and white so
the whole camouflage thing that's just
not working out so well as a hypothesis
okay so by law biologists go and they
decide to take a look at some zebras and
so they're looking at a zebra at on the
herd because there's no zebra right just
like there's no fish there are schools
of fish and there are herds of zebras
there isn't a fish this is why I think
the cod aren't coming back there are no
Cod there are massive hundred mile long
schools of cod ten stories deep 20
million years old you wipe out the
school you don't just get to throw a cod
in the water and say well you know ops
go it's like well where's my city
it's like launching you in the middle of
a field it's like well go out there and
reproduce like no that's not going to
happen you know so without the school
there's no Cod and you can't just
introduce a whole school of cod because
you don't have a whole school of cod so
you know maybe the cod are never coming
back and zebras are the same thing
there's not a zebra they're zebras and
so you're looking at the Zebras trying
to study a zebra and you look at the
zebra and you make some notes if you
look up and you think oh Christ which
zebra was I looking at and the answer to
that is you don't know because the the
camouflage is against the herd and the
black and white stripes there's a
variety of reasons for the stripes flies
off also seem not to like the stripes
but you know usually people things
evolve for multiple reasons but anyways
it's very difficult to parse out a zebra
against the herd you look down you look
up it's like oh all those damn zebras
look the same yes the camouflage is
effective but it's against the herd all
right so then you think well we better
identify a zebra so we can see what he's
up to
so then you take your Jeep and a can of
red paint and a stick with a rag on the
end of it you drive up to the Z
and you paint their haunch red a little
bit put a nice red dot on their haunts
or maybe clip their ear with a cattle
clip and then you you know you stand
back and saying hey I'm pretty smart now
I'm going to watch that zebra so what do
you think happens to the zebra the Lions
kill it right right right
because lions they're smart right hunter
hunting animals are smart but they have
to identify a zebra before they can
organize their hunt they can't just hunt
the whole herd they have to pick out a
zebra and so maybe it's like a zebra
that's got a sore hip or something and
so you think well nature's kind it just
takes the week it's though no zebra or
Lions like really healthy delicious
zebras but they look like all the other
healthy delicious zebras so they can't
get a bead on them but if they're small
and just born or if they're limping or
there's something that identifies them
then the Lions can pick them out and
then they do pick them out and so the
rule for human beings is keep your damn
stripes on so the Lions don't get you
and I'm telling you man if you want to
remember one thing from my class about
human motivation that's a good thing to
learn people camouflage themselves
against the herd and they like to be in
the middle of the herd which is what
fish do by the way if you have a big
school of fish the smart healthy large
fish are in the middle of the school
because you know what you call fish on
the outside of the school bait right so
that's what people are doing they're
trying to move into the middle of the
herd all the time and the herd moves
around or the school moves around and
people are going well I'm in the middle
I'm staying in the middle here so I've
got this protective ring of people
around me so the Predators don't pick me
out and do me in so okay so that's
that's part of the reason why I said
well you can't sell something to someone
for success because you know you're
thinking well people are aiming at
success don't don't be thinking that
it's not by any means necessarily true
trade neuroticism is a potential
powerful motivator and trait neuroticism
is let's not be too threatened or hurt
right that's the negative emotion system
and the negative emotion system is a
killer source of motivation you know you
also see that there are scales of
well-being that have been designed
mostly by social psychology
which means they're very bad scales most
of the time because they're psychometric
capacity is absurdly low generally
speaking so what you find with scales of
well-being
sometimes they're talked about as scales
of happiness even is that people aren't
after happiness they're after not
hurting it's not so they don't want to
be extroverted at enthusiastic right and
bubbly and and full of smiles and
laughter that isn't what they mean by I
want to be happy what they mean is I
don't want to be anxious or in pain and
so well-being scales tend to be
something like neuroticism sorry
emotional stability plus extraversion
but the big loading is on emotional
stability the reverse of neuroticism you
want to avoid suffering you don't want
to be happy you want to avoid suffering
and one way to avoid suffering is not to
let the liens gnaw on you and one way of
doing that is to stay in the middle of
the damn hurt and so and like I'm not
being a smart aleck about this I
understand why people do that there's
real danger to being visible there's
real danger in being visible now you
might be successful if you're visible
but you also might be dead